foreign
[Music]
also the bank called
hey brother Joe I got something to tell
you dad I got a call yesterday from a
guy at a record company he says he heard
our record and uh our record
what do you mean dreaming wild
great to meet you I wanted to talk to
you about this there it is it's raining
wild that's you guys yeah that's us this
album is unbelievable truly it really
just blew my mind how did you do it
Donnie made it all right here
Johnny what you got going on over there
I'm just playing around Donny's a genius
truthfully and then what happened we're
gonna need some more money to get these
last few songs finished my dad lost a
lot we find albums that never found an
audience we try to give them a second
chance and based on all the buzz the
record has got because you've seen that
right during its finest moments to twist
the Brian Wilson phrase dreaming wild is
a god-like symphony to Dean Hood all
right Wilson yeah
well heck let's celebrate
you got a gift gotta use it I believe in
you boys
New York Times want to do a story on you
guys are you kidding me and now he wants
it to be the kickoff for a tour so weird
to have this now I'm not sure what to do
with all of it
I have spent my whole life trying to
make music it's just fun for you it's
not just fun for me
[Music]
we're so happy I just didn't know
anything about the world
things were a lot easier when I was a
teenager
[Music]
sorry to have for putting you through
all of it
[Music]
you're my son I would have gladly given
up all the land just here you play